on this episode I taped the episode tape
I record the episode getting off the
plane from the Superbowl how do you
think it went you ask questions and I
answer them this is the askgaryvee
sup everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching episode number 66 of
the askgaryvee show you might also be
listening to it I need to Anita stop
saying watching I think I've done that
for the last couple episodes as you can
tell I just got off a plane my flight
was canceled yesterday from errors I
mean let's just tell the whole story
bottom line was said I wasn't gonna
watch the Superbowl some of you know
that my business partner in vayner/rse
my fund uh is uh Steve Ross the owner of
the Miami Dolphins he invited me to
Super Bowl with him you know the owners
parties all that stuff you know I
thought it would be good for me to start
used to it with what the future holds
and so I suckered myself made a
humongous mistake promised myself I
would never watch the Patriots in a
Super Bowl in case they won not only
that happened but I ended up being there
and then everybody knows since the whole
world watched what unfolded so you know
stuff on me tried to make me feel a
little bit better as I just got here off
the plane that you know Lisa got it was
funny was like at least I got another
prediction right so you know I don't
know if you can do the recall but you
might as well do a little editing d-roc
I know it's a little later let's go to
the moment where I say that I think the
Patriots are going to win
27:12 Patriots this Sunday that is my
firm prediction I equally do not want
that to happen but I did say on this
show that I wanted them to stick into my
face and hit rock bottom it looks like
they're trying to execute but they do
cheat yep so rock bottom tastes
delicious that's what I've got right now
let's go into the show David asks I'm at
the point where I need to hire an office
assistant sales are great but I don't
necessarily have the capital to pull the
trigger any creative ideas on how to
achieve this maybe this is a great
question you really it's really fun to
be in the presence of d-roc one of the
people who I think paid forward and is
going to feel the huge dividends on the
way back meaning I know a lot of your
hardcore Watchers and listeners uh and
know that Iraq first did a video for me
for free that clapton dirt oh that's
epic let's link that up
and you know that led to a relationship
which led to a full-time gig and now
will be my heart and soul as long as
he'll have me in my video world which
you know superbowl videos of jets
winning things you never know Dirac ah
so you know I think one of the things
you can do is use your social capital to
put out there that you're looking for
somebody and that this is how you can
compensate obviously money is the
accepted compensation in our society but
I got to tell you like I think that
there is a day and age with the internet
being a middle platform where other
things can be used and so I don't know
what obviously you just felt an edit
because d-roc screwed up kind of like
Pete Carroll at the one-yard line
by not double-checking the card was I'm
not double checking the card of the card
went weird on you okay let you messed up
all right let's you get a little D ROC
messed up alert I want to make sure I'm
gonna double-check this just so you know
I do double checks I want to see if it's
pretty and it better be really
over-the-top you rock the d-roc best up
alert letter be legit cuz it only
happens once every 66 episode anybody
think it's interesting that's episode 66
one more six devil the Patriots one
belcheck um and so anyway uh going back
not showing where it got cut off but
just make sure you edit it we argue
rocks every buddy knows there was a
mistake on your end um I think that uh
there's just a lot of ways to be able to
barter out that service I would
literally put on Craigslist and on your
social media and email blasts and take
your ten closest friends and have them
blast and say look I'm looking for this
this is what I can offer
maybe that's minimum wage plus I'll give
you all my services for free for a year
or there's just a million ways to hack I
think that we in our modern society
across the globe outside of very rural
part pockets in parts of the world that
you know I'm not educated enough to know
this we are really in a flat-out
currency exchange game and I'm a big
believer that over the next 50 years
because the internet shrinks the middle
there'll be an opportunity as a matter
of fact I'm gonna make another
prediction Stefan
that there will be a major platform in
the next 15 years that is a major top 50
startup that is infrastructure for us to
trade like straight up like eBay
Craigslist mobile you know
prick where it's just like you know I
have this coat laying around and
sometimes I cool I'll mow your lawn like
you know like just there's just so much
inefficiency in stuff and services
provided I think you should go that
route maybe make a video maybe take the
momentum off this answer and go really
do something the other thing is to
really pound the streets meaning just
like no no rock unturned right just ask
a lot of people there's a lot of people
out there and I think in our society not
paying in cash feels like taking
advantage I think I've consistently been
on the offense in nuances of like barter
exchange I just think there's a lot that
can be done maybe a but maybe you have a
collection of rare baseball cards that
somebody wants or you know you have 14
pairs of awesome Nikes and maybe you can
have sex you Bassets around you your
time your services a crapload of stuff
in your house trade that for what you
need or go with do you have a good
enough of a name to make a promise that
hey I can pay you this but I promise you
as soon as we get going
I'm going to make you the full-time
person I think the one thing that I
promise you that you need to make sure
you do is a lot of people promise and
don't deliver and I highly recommend you
don't make that promise unless you feel
like you can deliver and the reason I
make so many promises I always say to
myself even if I fail business-wise I'll
go to my own bank account and close the
gap like when if you're willing to go to
that level and I don't know your
personal finances but anyway barter
barter barter hey gary vaynerchuck this
is Colin Warren aka DJ vu here and I've
got one question for you honest I know
you've talked about it on Twitter before
but I'd love to hear your thoughts on
this specific platform thanks my man
keep up the great work
I like this young hustler or someone
about him I've seen this video before
I've seen him interact a little bit
there's something about this kid I'm
just saying it now on the record so I
can be right up with another prediction
step on 17 years from today this kid is
gonna have some juice and I don't know
if in the music world but like I just
can feel it anyway take that and run
with a kid it's good momentum um you
know I think it's 15-second videos right
like you just did
I'm pumped that you made a video and the
answer is predicated on the
communication format I think for
musicians - OH
index on Instagram it's going to have to
be around the music and I think the
15-second video format works I think
using the right hashtags is the way to
be discovered
I think reaching out to other Instagram
influencers in the space matters so
hitting people up finding what you know
a ton of in-store Ian's people are
putting their emails in there now a lot
of those people are getting compensated
financially and you know I have no idea
of your finances but I'm going to be
prejudiced or assume that on the younger
side it's not unlimited but again back
to like this is maybe this is the theme
of the show there's probably a ton of
Instagram Fuji's and muscle dudes who
have huge huge followings that you can
hit up and say look I'll make you a
15-second theme song or something for
your world if you can give a little love
to me in return if I were you and man do
what am i pissed that the internet
wasn't around when I was 14 15 16 17 18
19 I'm it was around but normal people
not straight-up nerds the internet
itself is basically 20 years old and I
know there's some nerd in the background
like oh I'm actually 1959 I know father
but I mean when normal people went on I
really really think that uh I think that
I would just spend 17 18 hours a day
hitting up people via email on the
Instagram accounts going to going to
explore finding some people that are
popular hitting their accounts seeing
that they have over a hundred thousand
followers and just pounding them with
emails saying hey I make music I'll make
some music for you I'm looking for
exposure but just be very upfront don't
try to trick them like oh if you make it
make a song and something interesting
can happen I many beverages does a man
need oh okay Mike got me coffee to
double-fisted what um
and so uh so you know that's that's the
route I would go you need as much of
exposure as possible
you're in an Instagram community get
into the trenches a lot of those people
going to look for money they won't say
yes but I'm telling you you will get
four yeses for every eight hundred
emails and for a lot of people listening
that's a lot of time for four yeses but
the truth is what's the alternative
losing JD asks
I have an Instagram account let's meet
but building followers pretty fast what
do you think about selling advertising
like a 15-second commercial to people
wanting to reach my audience gaming
first of all I'm in love with your
Instagram account super pumped for it
you know super nice very crush it like
the culmination of that for me so feels
cool another prediction global
prediction that I drilled um uh and so
I'm just kidding this this is the worst
day uh uh first of all you 585 followers
so you're only going to be able to get
as much money as you know a walk in the
park so first I would focus on the next
six to 12 months this is yes I do think
once every seven Jab Jab Jab right hook
you know once every seven Instagram
videos for you to make a commercial is
super appropriate will work and if you
can make it more entertainment
commercial like you starring in it think
1950s and 60s television I know a lot of
your youngsters but the original
commercials were very integrated even
into the 70s
Alpo I think it was you know the dog
food was getting dogs to come on the set
of the Today Show and eat the food you
know and so you know that that that's
been around forever and that's coming
back old is new like Missy Elliott you
see all the kids on social media being
like oh Katy Perry you put this Missy
Elliott on it's pretty intense to watch
all this kids need to get educated these
thirteen year olds are I love them
though I mean I believe that they're
winning they're right so just want
everybody know that anyway um what's
really interesting to me is that what I
would do for you I'm gonna I'm gonna
drop the helm flip it and reverse it on
you and give you a different answer you
need to basically Google volleyball
blogs volleyball media volleyball news
and you need to email every single
person on the first 80 pages of results
and tell them what you're doing and
seeing if you can get them to give you
exposure you should absolutely be
pounding the volleyball community right
now all 917 influencers that matter in
volleyball you need to know who you are
and you need to be the one that emails
em and says yo what's up period email
every volleyball manufacturer and we
like to check out what I'm doing guys
most of you were not taking it you
understand what I did with Wine Library
TV
okay I emailed everybody everybody that
was a wine blog in 2006 and said hey I'm
doing this and I get that not everybody
is as comfortable self-promoting and I
love with my friends from Europe or like
oh it's a very American thing and a lot
of people who are watching or
introverted or don't have as much hustle
look I'm a funny guy I'm very
competitive I was in super crazy
networking events at this weekend and
like the commissioners there and Woody
Johnson and you know all these actors
and actresses and VIPs and Hall of
Famers and I'm not going up to them
because I'm so competitive and ego I'm
like I'm gonna make them come to me but
there's a part of that that's super
wrong there they are and then I took
away that I took that away from myself
for a little bit and I went and did five
or six and I can't do it completely but
like you know taking those steps as well
so like for all my extrovert salesmen
stuff I have my own spiel that like
prevents me from taking it but I'm
telling you behind the keyboard emailing
volleyball daily calm and being like hey
it's me I'm doing this thing you should
just check it out I'd love to do
something be smart position it properly
not like hey look I'm doing this
Instagram thing about volleyball you
should write about me no that's right
hook jab like hey it's me I'm doing this
thing I love our community if there's
anything I can ever do for you let me
know
jab so take it Oh India got excited she
said cool I wasn't done yet India yeah
was it going right you want to write a
full pledge hardcore we're gonna write a
full hardcore next Boston asks what do
you mean when you say you focus on the
top-line revenue is it because you care
more about staying relevant and having
attention because you can cash in on
that for more sales
Boston no I talk about top-line revenues
answer's no that's not what I'm looking
to do I'm looking to drive top-line
revenue I'm doing it in vaynermedia
right now I'm glad my financial people
aren't here because they're like I'm not
sure what you're up to Gary but it's
super interesting here's what I'm up to
CFOs I'm a when you drive profit if you
bring in expenses like I have bringing
more and more people you may not make as
much money right away because if you're
making 12 million dollars and it cost
you twelve million dollars to run your
business you make zero dollars and if
the year before it cost you you know you
did
million in revenue but only cost 5.3
million and expenses to drive it you
made 2.7 in profits so even though
you're doing a lot more business this
year you're not making as much money but
that's also the human infrastructure and
the learnings and the people to be able
for you to do the 14 but 40 million next
year got it simple as that nothing else
you just got to make sure that your
expenses don't over go your sales
because then you can't make payroll and
you go out of business or you have bumps
in the road and things of that nature
and I as an entrepreneur have had a
substantially good career over 20 years
of pushing the limit of how much I can
take expenses and cash to be able to
grow my business and that is something
I'm always focused on I think it's super
important I know how to do it and that's
the reason I uniquely now have a second
business under my belt where I've taken
the business from 3 to over 50 million
dollars in revenue within a five-year
window that is unusual that is not the
norm and it talks to having a stomach
that wants to drive top-line and so
that's not for everybody and everybody's
got to be safe and want to make payroll
but a lot of you are not moving your
business faster because of lack of
offense lack of spending 18 hours a day
emailing 800 people on Instagram to know
about your music stuff you're lacking
offense I'm emailing every single person
talking about volleyball in the world on
the internet and saying hey Here I am
and you're lacking by not investing may
be doing the finances for that office
secretary who then will allow you to be
on the offense doing other things
instead of doing some damn paperwork boy
I tied that together like a champ hi
Gary
its Alicia from Alisha bags and I have
one important question for you this year
I've got a great bag coming out way
higher quality than anything I've ever
done but more expensive - how do i
market that to my current audience much
of the question um you know the weird
answer is maybe you shouldn't if the
price point of your new bag is 300 bucks
and you've been selling $25 bags you
just might not want to market to your
current audience because they can't
maybe afford to buy that bag now maybe
they can like you know I buy $20 things
I buy 500 other things in the same
category so you know that's not whole
hmm and like
but the way fashion is going so
interesting to me by the way little fun
back but anyway I think that it is very
important for you to understand much
like the advice that I've given the
prior two questions that you may have to
go out and find a new audience and
that's scary that might not be like I'm
thinking right now as you're watching
I'm curious how you're watching leave in
the comments are you watching like this
or on a laptop or really curious how
you're consuming this um do it uh but
the truth is you may have to go out and
find a new audience and that's by
putting yourself out there and engaging
with others I think influencers on
Instagram are massively important so I
think you can get away with giving away
some of these bags to some of those
influencers and getting them on the
cheap in my opinion so I would
definitely go down the Instagram
influencer path I think if you give away
five to ten bags to the people that have
let's say 250,000 and more who actually
would take the bag and give that love I
think you have a shot of being stunned
by the ROI in today's world so that's
what I would go out and do and so the
answer to your question is how do you
remark it to them you remark it to them
to go up you let them know about it and
you know 5 to 15% of that audience will
grow up with you financially or
aspirationally but I think you have to
go out and find out and find and hunt
the 85% of the rest of the audience just
want to take a couple minutes before I
go into the question a day and give some
love to the people that are consistently
commenting on the show which means a ton
to me I thought it was an appropriate
time not asking for the lurkers to come
out though this would be a phenomenal
episode to leave a comment in the
questions or in the comment section on
YouTube lurkers and the ones that are
listening on the podcast so let's start
with Chad asks really appreciate your
brother you're consistent you're driving
it I'm seeing you feeling you thank you
Roberto
I think you've been completely on the
offense not only are you responding
consistently to the question of the day
but your engagement within the Vayner
community your your insanity of
intensity is appreciated and we have
much lovely Roberto here at the
askgaryvee show Ruth you've been with me
long before the askgaryvee show as
somebody you know it's funny like a lot
of people by the way have been telling
me to change my icon on Twitter and one
of the reasons I don't
on two is because Ruth you've been very
consistent to its visual right like I
know who's there I see you in all my
screams I really appreciate your
commenting you always bring a lot of
Grace and class to the comment section
much mucho love to you Thomas I love you
holding down the the youth culture and
for the vaynernation uh doing a great
job really tight and consistent with
your comments and we really just
appreciate you man I'm really look I'm
really really flattered by the people
are consistently commenting I think
brings so much that's gonna affect a
side question day how many of you
actually read the comments because
you're getting so much value there
so Thomas you're a big part of that I
appreciate it Victoria Jaya I don't even
know what it is really about you but
every time I see your comments I smile
um seeing them super consistently I
really appreciate it
you run the gamut of like just
off-the-cuff stuff and and really
hardcore answers I appreciate that as
somebody who loves your off-the-cuff
stuff as well and so I really really
really appreciate you all of you all
five of you I really appreciate there's
many more many of you know doc and chef
and you've gotten your love as well but
I'm seriously interested you know
honestly and I did this with Wine
Library TV ad and I don't want to boast
to you
I am a feedback animal I'm a feedback
animal that's just what it is like
without the comment section without the
question I mean the Instagram the
Instagram questions are not coming in as
fast as I like so you know let's link
that up without that without the Twitter
hashtags it phases away from me so like
look if you're listening if you're
driving to work right now or working out
listening to the podcast or if you're
watching which is very easy because
you're on your phone or your laptop or
iPad right now I need more comments in
the comment section it's just simple as
that and and the people that have been
doing it for me as a matter of fact that
should be the statement of day all of
you should go in and thank your favorite
one of those five people because it's
those people that are like guys I will
quit this show in your face in four
seconds I'm plenty [ __ ] busy I will
quit this show you want me to do it feed
me
I need the fuel and that's the
interaction that's the engagement
question of the day how do you consume
this show this
like like like this like you know you
know TV OTT like iPad I need the answer
curious you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
what do you mean we focus on top-line
revenue is it because you care more
about staying relevant having attention
because you cash in on that for more
sales all right yeah put that put that
at the end to get beat and does not mean